before before I actually start I need a
couple of things from you guys I need an
iPhone six-plus does anyone have an
iPhone six-plus can I borrow that I will
I will not damage it I promise you was
very reluctant always Canadian that's
why thank you very much
and I also need a tissue I didn't I
didn't bring my own tissues and I need I
really need a tissue oh okay perfect
all right okay with that I can actually
go in character and do this talk I am
I'm running Windows 2000 I've seen a lot
of very startup sound I've seen a lot of
very amazing operating systems that look
like they must be experimental Apple
projects but I'm running good old
Windows 2000
all right my name is Gary Bernhardt I'm
very happy to be here at demo comp and
this talk is a survey of where we are
how we got here where we might go and
how great everything is this is the
stock price of Apple over roughly the
last year from quarter four ninety nine
until now you can see there was a brief
uptick and then it has crashed to about
ten percent of of its stock pricey
about a year ago Microsoft is a little
bit better off they are they're down to
about half what they were a year ago
simultaneously with this I don't think
it's a coincidence this has happened in
the same year that Linux has become very
usable on the desktop this is this is
enlightenment 16 running the brushed
metal theme probably the most widely
used one there are many others this is a
really cool theme there are some that
are just really strange and if i zoom in
you can see there are super cool fonts
in this enlightenment theme and I think
what's I don't know what table 2 is I'm
sorry this I think what's happening here
is that Linux on the desktop has finally
become viable and everyone is switching
to it and that is what is happening to
Microsoft and Apple and this is
happening because no one wants
proprietary operating systems
everyone now even our parents understand
that software freedom freedom as in
speech is the most important thing about
a software system and regular people now
care about this which means the
mainstream is switching now you may have
noticed that I'm running Windows 2000
there is a reason that I'm doing that
and that is I could not get external
displays to work I am sure that external
displays will be working at any time in
the near future because with many bug or
with many eyes all bugs are shallow you
you may recognize this guy this is a
bonsai buddy but
before your parents switched to Linux on
their desktops you may have had to
remove this from their machines or you
may have had to deal with a lot of
toolbars on their machines and of course
everyone knows pop-unders you close your
browser window and there's a there's
another window under it with an ad in it
all of these are terrible scourge is
that we want to fight we want to fight
these invasive forms of advertising now
we are making some technical headway
here
Mozilla now blocks pop-ups as of a few
months ago so that's a great start but I
think what's going to happen in the long
term is that we no one likes
advertisements right nobody chooses to
see them and we all know that the web is
a free democratic meritocracy and if it
is true that the web gives the users of
the web what they want and no one wants
ads then it must also be true that the
ads will die and I think that's what's
happening I think that's what we're
seeing with with this push back against
pop-ups now at this point in the talk
for some reason I often get a nosebleed
and it's as if my bot my body is
rejecting something in deeply
contradictory in my mind but there's
nothing contradictory here so I don't
know what that would be but I'm going to
just preemptively take care of that for
a moment so I'll be I'll be right back
just I'm sorry this is very vulgar for
me to do this but oh okay
I feel I feel much better now now this
is the the w3 C's page for their markup
languages and I want to highlight part
of it for you the the w3 s work provides
richer web pages on an ever-increasing
range of browser platforms including
cell phones televisions cars wallet size
wallet communicators your wallet size
wireless communicators kiosks and
desktops when they say wallet size while
it but I can't even say that wallet size
wireless communicator I think they mean
something like a like a palm write this
is actually a handspring visor but it's
a clone of a palm this is not wireless
unfortunately but in the near future you
can imagine these being Wireless and and
the web has to adapt to that or when
they say a cell phone they mean
something like my brand new Nokia 82 60
and this thing it's a great phone I
recommend it it's my first cell phone
it's really it's it's weird to be
connected all the time this this phone
does not have web support but things
like this will soon be supporting web
technologies this is another part of the
same page they're talking about XHTML
here which is HTML as an XML schema and
they say the modular design of XHTML
reflects the realization that a
one-size-fits-all approach will no
longer work in a world where browsers
very enormous leaner capabilities a
browser and cell phone can't etc etc so
the w3c knows that the technology is
changing that the devices are changing
and they're updating the standards to
fit them and I think that this is
wonderful a wonderful thing that's
happening that they know they see the
problems coming and are adapting to them
in advance
there are many web standards of course
not just like stage tml there's CSS
which is pretty widely used now there's
ecla script which you probably haven't
heard of but this is it's the it's the
standardized form of JavaScript and it's
really a wonderful story because because
Brendan only had ten days to design the
the JavaScript programming language and
fortunately thousands of people have
dedicated hundreds of thousands of hours
of their human finite lives to
standardizing that language not changing
it but just standardizing it and right
all down and arguing about what the real
semantics are etc etc so that's
wonderful
moving on to our fourth and final topic
before we merge all these together this
is a plot of the number of transistors
in various CPUs over time my first
computer four years ago in 96 was a 46
you can see that Pentium 4 has far far
more transistors and this has always
been true it just keeps going up and up
and I can't see anyway any reason to
this would stop happening in the near
future or even the distant future it
seems like it just has to keep going and
going and going and getting better and
better this on the other hand is the
size of computers over time and this is
a logarithmic scale so the first
programmable general-purpose electrical
electronic computer was the ENIAC in 46
it was about if you made it a cube it
would be 4 meters on a side that's a big
cube pdp-1 is about the size of a phone
booth IBM PC is maybe the size of this
podium an iBook the new laptop from
Apple you've probably seen one of those
and then my 82 60 is about point zero
zero zero zero one square meter or cubic
meters as opposed to 64 cubic meters for
an e niak now I don't see any reason
that this would stop happening I mean
computers have to keep getting smaller
right as time goes on devices are only
going to get smaller in the future 15
years from now we'll probably this thing
will be the size of a postage stamp I
imagine and we'll just kind of unfold it
and do our computering and just kind of
wrinkle it up and throw it in our pocket
or something so hard we're always gets
better
CPUs get faster and faster I mean where
we're going to be at 800 megahertz than
a gigahertz then 2 gigahertz and 4 than
8 then 16 gigahertz it's never going to
stop doubling at any time disks are
going to keep getting bigger you're
going to have a one gig drive one year
later two gigs then 4 then 8 and 16
every single year just like we always
have devices are going to keep getting
smaller this phone will look comically
large in 15 years I'm sure
so we've talked about four topics we
have we have the rise of Linux on the
desktop we have the death of advertising
we have these increasing HTML standards
like it's XHTML that are going to adapt
to the future web needs of the future
needs of web systems and we have
Hardware getting smaller and smaller and
faster and faster and now I want to
imagine what future all of these could
could combine to give us
well the devices of course are going to
be smaller I imagined something postage
stamp-sized would be a really nice form
factor they're going to be running Linux
open source top to bottom because why
wouldn't they be open source is clearly
better as we all know browsing a web
without ads and running some kind of
applications that are using like very
strict correct markup using very
powerful static languages maybe derive
from Java maybe even Drive from
JavaScript
who knows maybe some other third thing
that doesn't even exist yet now my
clicker not working there we go
I'm now going to I think my nosebleed is
done so I'm just going to give me a
second and I'll be right back
again I'm just going to leave this over
here so things are getting better and
better software is getting better and
better all the time
and I want to just sort of sort of
summarize my my message for you
here the way to the future is just to do
more of the same
just keep doing the same thing we've
always done x86 it's been great so far
you know take it to a gigahertz take it
to - take it to 4 8 gigahertz just keep
making it faster and faster HTML I mean
it's been pretty great for the last 7
years just keep just keep doing it I
guess for a few decades no need to
change it even really XML a little bit
even JavaScript you know everyone hates
JavaScript I mean who here has ever
written JavaScript on purpose like
there's there's the one man in the back
corner
I respect you sir but no one no one
chooses JavaScript however I think that
if we really try really hard we might be
able to over the course of a decade or
two convince ourselves that we might
actually like it a little bit I I'm
optimistic that we can do that if we
really want to and most importantly
remember everything always gets better
nothing ever addresses everything just
marches forward in a straight monotonic
line towards perfection
Clippy suggested this I'm not sure why I
think it might be the word future that
got me this gift but I'm not sure to
close out I really I would like to I
would like to thank so that possibly
really paid off
I would like to thank our platinum level
sponsor excite at home I think they're
going to be doing big things them it's
the the merger of two wonderful
companies I'd like to thank our
organizer Jen Schiffer for putting this
on and for for inviting me to speak I
like to thank Clippy for just suggesting
all those great pictures so thank you
very much